we got we got echo charles here he's a
good salesman let's put him in charge of
sales what does he know about leadership
he doesn't know anything about leading
and we just throw him in there people
think that leadership is something
you're just born with or that you you
know how to do it in intuitively and
it's just factually not true so what we
encourage and what you're actually doing
is we're going to take you and we're
going to elevate you into a leadership
position and we're going to train you
how to lead you've got someone right now
making a decision in a basement and that
individual is making the right decision
as a leader on the front lines he's
empowered to do that you couldn't help
that person make that decision except
for the fact that you already have
helped them because you trained him as a
leader they understand the culture they
understand the mission of the company
and when you do that it allows you to to
to drive a company forward with people
at every level leading making the right
decisions and moving in the same
direction strategically